yo Brad we must celebrate the fabulous
getting on which is now it's in America
it is slightly up the gamma okay what
were you wearing and dined by Hollywood
agents and things no I didn't go Tyson
go over there know what they're making
your show in America you didn't go
that's right
check and come well I think what check
anything by a post what have you ever
been to America now you've never been to
America and fun is that illegal
no so ignorant joke I am Colin that's
why people like me in the world I'd
rather go than America all of them soon
country in the world in the best of
America
from Burma under Ukraine Winfred which
have no billion times better
Jamie was opposite me and so let's start
with you Joe how would you improve the
BBC and I said sac Jeremy Clarkson
Pamela Anderson yeah who bases a lot of
her act or merely person in her costume
is you in your costume